[MUSIC]
Great leaders are committed to
developing other people as leaders,
which often means putting them in
positions where they might fail.
Encouraging them to step
outside their comfort zone and
helping them learn from setbacks and
mistakes as opposed to punishing them for
setbacks and mistakes immediately.
[MUSIC]
Great leaders also really internalize the
responsibility to embody the culture and
to walk the talk.
It's a truism in organizational life
that sort of the values plaque,
the principles that we put up
on the wall is kind of BS.
And I think that's because in a lot
of circumstances people see a big gap
between the plaque on the wall and
the leaders actual behavior.
They are finely tuned to have moments
where the leader is not acting
in alignment with those principles.
And so I think great leadership really
means committing to understanding those
principles, internalizing them.
And being very deliberate about following
through on them, especially when they
don't align with what the leader
believes to be their self interest.
If a leader is going to follow the values
on the plaque on the wall only when it's
personally expedient, I'd say that
creates, very toxic environment in which
people realize those values on
the wall are not going to be followed.
They're not ones that we
need to listen to either.
[MUSIC]
A theme that comes up a lot in my practice
is that leaders occupy a particularly
important symbolic role.
And I think this is often neglected
in contemporary organizational life.
We tend to think of leaders
as decision makers,
we think of leaders in
a very strategic sense.
They're going to determine
the course of the organization,
and they're going to set strategy, and
they're going to allocate resources.
That's all true.
It's also very cognitive.
I think what that leaves out is
the emotional impact that a leader has as
the symbolic leader of the tribe.
The symbolic dimension of organizational
life is one that comes up quite a lot in
my practice.
People join organizations and feel
committed to organizations to a certain
extent because of the feeling of community
that they enjoy among their colleagues.
And the commitment that they feel from the
leader to sort of invest in the health and
development growth of that community.
It doesn't mean that a leader is
obligated to solve for those factors, but
recognizing the leader bears a unique
responsibility to help that community feel
a sense of collective identity and growth.
[MUSIC]
Great leaders are also able to make
a distinction between leading and doing.
Many of the people I work with
have a technical background,
either as coders or developers,
as investors or financial analysts.
And they've achieved their leadership
position by virtue of their technical
prowess.
And that is often very useful in the early
stages of a company's development because
other people are looking to leader for
that kind of technical expertise.
And yet if a leader remains
stuck in the process of doing,
if they are essentially the doer in chief.
If their leadership rests on their ability
to be the most effective person at that
particular technical discipline or the
proverbial smartest person in the room.
Then they're going to cap
the organization's ability to grow.
They will inhibit the organization's
capacity to scale.
So a transitional phase that I help
a lot of leaders navigate through is
this period of being the most technically
adept person in a given discipline.
To a phase in which they're
actually adding value,
not on the basis of their technical
expertise, because they're
hiring people who have deeper expertise
in their particular discipline.
And so the leader is not adding value by
telling that technical expert how to do
their job or by, even worse,
kind of shouldering that person out of
the way and doing their job for them.
But by bringing a group of
technically adept people together and
helping them operate as a team, ultimately
that distinction between leading and
doing is how a leader truly
helps an organization scale.
[MUSIC]